duda knows it's over
not thrilled
looked like he was playing good chess
the first couple rounds here then this
then
it got out of control
for yan shisht of duda
but yeah i think you're right this
nepaleshi game because it felt like yeah
different cluster must have been a blow
with that of course there's also
tiredness with all the preparation
and it's it's higher stakes than your
regular super tournament or even a world
cup where he gets maybe some opponents
he can dominate that's absolutely
because dude has shown he can play with
the best he beat magnus in the world cup
semi-finals
but here yeah
it's going to
and we all know the pain of sitting
there knowing you're lost and you're
looking for a way to continue the game
while going through the five stages of
brief simultaneously
yeah
it looks like he's getting ready to
resign did he resign
or did he make a move
saying he resigned yeah he was waiting
for
richie to come back to the board so he
could resign richie wouldn't show up so
he just lost patience and resigned
without
and rapport wins his first game